From awesome Thena action, lost-in-time Captain
America shields, a deleted Batman parody,
and up to nine alternate endings, there's
a lot that Marvel deleted from the final version
of Eternals.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm revealing all the cut scenes
and characters, alternate post-credit scenes,
and Deviant designs that ended up getting
the chop.
Spoilers ahead, of course, so take care.
There was a great looking scene with Thena
in the first trailer that didn't make it into
the movie which seems to be part of what Makkari
and Kingo's actors have described as a visually
spectacular deleted scene set during the flashback
to the Gupta empire.
The scene involved a lot of silk and would
have established the two types of Eternals;
the thinkers, that's Sersi, Ajak, Phastos,
Sprite and Druig;
and the fighters, that's Ikaris, Gilgamesh,
Thena, Makkari, and Kingo.
It was intended to show how the family were
both dysfunctional and fun at the same time,
but was cut for pacing which, given the length
of the movie, makes sense.
What's especially intriguing about this deleted
scene is that this guy here is carrying a
shield very similar to Steve Roger's famous
Captain America shield.
That's strange because chronologically in
the main MCU timeline, it was Howard Stark
who first created Cap's shield in the 20th
century, whereas the Gupta scenes in Eternals
take place in 400 AD, many hundreds of years
earlier.
Steve Rogers did, of course, decide to go
time-travelling at the end of Avengers: Endgame
for his rendezvous with Peggy Carter, and
he also brought back a new Captain America
shield for Sam Wilson.
So, did he also decide to go back further
in time and have something to do with the
shield we see in this scene?
Alternatively, and more likely, Phastos invented
this shield and kept it in storage on the
Eternals ship and released the idea for it
later on in time to Howard Stark, similar
to how he slowly introduces other technology
over the years to humankind in this film.
A line widely used in the Eternals trailers
and TV spots but which didn't make it into
the final movie is when Ikaris says…
Eternals assemble.
It's a really good line.
It's a nod, of course, to the comics and that
awesome moment when Cap finally said the famous
line in Endgame as he called for Earth's Mightiest
Heroes to wade into battle against Thanos.
Avengers!
Assemble.
Another deleted line from the trailers would
have come at the end of the movie when Sprite
is sitting with Ikaris watching the volcano
erupt as the Emergence begins.
If this is what the end of the world looks
like, at least we have front row seats.
A character I really enjoyed in the movie
was Kingo and the comedic moments that both
he and his human friend Karun brought to the
story.
The documentary they begin filming on Kingo's
jet is hilarious, and reminds me of the Thor
mockumentaries;
and, in fact, there's an Avengers name-drop
in the trailers that was cut from the final
movie.
Avengers..
Thor..
Spider-Man.
Another deleted scene from Kingo's jet has
Sprite holding a microphone and performing
what looks like karaoke.
The others behind her appear to be sleeping
and, given there's several cocktails on the
bar, it looks like this is some kind of party
scene on the jet.
An area where I thought the movie did impress
was its visual style, especially the Deviants
which had some particularly striking looks.
The scene where their leader Kro uses his
tentacles to transform the other Deviants
in the cave into monstrous winged and wolf-like
creatures was especially shocking.
However, there were some even more horrifying
Deviant designs that didn't make it into the
film.
Leaked concept art shows frog-like creatures
and scorpion-style monsters that weren't in
the final movie.
The frog-like Deviant might have been based
on the Marvel character Brother Tode, who
in the comics was a ruler of the ancient Deviant
empire and also commanded the Deviant warlord
Kro.
The name on the concept art for the scorpion
Deviant indicates the creature was based on
a mythological Mesopotamian half-human, half-scorpion
creature.
I think this would have been an especially
interesting Deviant for the Babylonian attack,
given how these scorpion creatures appear
in the Epic of Gilgamesh.
Interestingly, the real-world myths of the
Scorpion Men say they were created by the
ocean goddess Tiamat, whose name is reminiscent
of Tiamut, the Celestial whose birth in the
Indian Ocean is stopped by Sersi.
These other Deviant designs, which appear
to be by concept artist Tully Summers, seem
to have inspired the look of some of the other
versions of the Deviants in the movie, such
as the winged monster, the wolf-like beast,
and the long-legged almost spider-like creatures.
Some of the humanoid designs also appear to
be the inspiration for Kro's more human-like
appearance that he acquires as the movie goes
on.
As well as deleted antagonists, there were
also two Eternal characters cut from the final
film.
Director Chloe Zhao revealed that there were
12 Eternals in the original script, but that
two of them had to be "let go".
And co-screenwriters Kaz and Ryan Firpo elaborated
on Deadline's podcast saying that although
Marvel initially asked for 12 characters,
after the first draft, they felt it was just
too many brand new characters to introduce
all at once to the MCU audience.
One of those deleted characters was Vampiro,
a somewhat obscure Eternal, who despite his
name and fangs, isn't a vampire.
In fact, he's more of a Batman knock-off in
terms of his suit, look, and use of high-tech
gadgets.
Given the numerous DC references already in
the movie…
That's Superman with the cape and you're shooting
laser beams out of your eyes,
…a Batman-style character would certainly
have fit in, however, it's just as well the
number of Eternals was cut down because even
with 10 the film did feel somewhat overstuffed.
And thinking back to Guardians of the Galaxy,
for example, their team began with just five
new characters.
In true Marvel style, Eternals has a couple
of post-credits scenes setting up new storylines
in the MCU;
however, screenwriter Kaz Firpo has revealed
that there were a total of nine post-credit
scenes originally considered for the film.
In an interview with Metro, he explained that
each of the
"possible versions of [the] ending told [a]
different story [with] different characters
[and] different ideas",
and he added that that some of them were "really
spicy".
Given what we know about Marvel's upcoming
movie slate, other possibilities for the end-credits
scenes could have been Doctor Strange 2 or
Thor: Love and Thunder.
But, what would you have liked to have seen?
While discussing his stunt work and training,
Druig actor Barry Keoghan revealed that his
mind-controlling character had at least one
fight scene cut from the film.
In an interview with Comic Book Movie, he
said that writer-director
"Chloe had written a boxing scene [and his
character] was avoiding punches and the tail,
and stuff like that."
Which sounds like he might have had a fight
scene with either Ikaris and also perhaps
Kro, or possibly another Deviant, given he
says Druig was avoiding a tail.
By the way, interestingly enough, actor Keoghan
is also a bit of an amateur boxer in real
life.
Some other scenes cut from the film include
shots in the trailer of a longer opening scene,
Sersi passing her hand over crops in Babylon,
which has echoes of Thanos the farmer in Endgame
tending to his crops.
And Ajak saying
"Hell, yes"
during her reunion with Ikaris at the house
in South Dakota.
And it wouldn't be a Marvel movie, without
some altered trailer scenes that ended up
quite different in the final film.
In the past, these have been done either to
avoid giving away spoilers or just filmed
exclusively for promotional purposes.
So, in the first Eternals trailer when Thena
wields her sword at this moment her eyes are
normal, whereas in the movie this scene takes
place while she has the Mahd Wy'ry, and so
her eyes are actually white.
When Sersi says "it's beautiful" to Ikaris
in the first trailer, it appears to happen
as the Eternals are arriving on Earth, whereas
in the movie this moment happens just after
the Eternals have been created and the view
outside the window is very different with
Sersi and Ikaris looking down on Earth from
space.
And when Ikaris suggests he could lead the
Avengers now that Iron Man and Steve Rogers
aren't around, the trailer has everyone bursting
into laughter.
So now that Captain Rogers and Iron Man are
both gone, who do you think's going to lead
the Avengers?
I could lead them.
[laughter]
In the movie, however, that reaction doesn't
happen, and instead Kingo agrees with Ikaris
whereas Gilgamesh simply points out that Ajak
didn't even choose him to lead the Eternals.
Another alternate trailer scene is a cool
close-up of Makkari speed-reading her way
through a book, whereas in the final movie
the shot is only seen from much further out
and doesn't quite have the same effect.
So, do you wish any of these deleted scenes
had been included in the film?
And how do you rate Eternals compared to your
favourite MCU movies?
Comment with your thoughts below.
And if you enjoyed this video, a thumbs-up
and a share are hugely appreciated.
Next you can tap left to learn about how Black
Widow's solo movie almost ended with her returning
from the dead.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!